e arrivato il momento di da chen d'aria
a noi due non sono bravissimo a tagliare
i capelli cioè non becca la macchinetta
non penso della chi sa che danno è però
devo fà un costume per fisico da robin
preservano ancora i capelli lunghi che
in caso alla prossima settimana è e
consumo onore che vi informo che sto
ufficialmente diventando un maiale sto
per farmi due hamburger non è una
puntata di proceno buttata in realtà è
un pezzo di blog mentre cucino volevo
raccontarvi una cosa fra ragazzi sto
mettendo anche scusate un rapportino di
guanciale del piano di questi panini e
secondo me sono perfetti bellissimi e un
po di formaggio tante il preso un raptus
ho iniziato a svuotare tutto quanto alla
ricerca della sorgente delle uova di
quelle farfallini me questo l'ho già
vinto tutto e ho beccato effettivamente
come mario nati detto voi create ragione
ci avevate ragione c'era un tipo delle
larve orribili che si nascondevano in
alcuni punti
io col però che non l'ho visto invece di
voler svuotare tutto è stare lì a
cercare cosa per cosa solo insorgendo
tutto come prese raptus omicida proprio
poche e anche questa è andata adesso
solamente di mettere tutta sta roba
laden secondo anche un muro di non
vogliano intelligente ora la domanda è
ma le farfalline stanno solamente nei
posti dove c'è il cibo o potrebbero
essere adesso ovunque nella casa
riaprire tutti i cassetti del mondo cioè
rispondere solamente se la sapete la
risposta e non tiriamo tentativi è il
giorno dopo
stavo cercando di dirvi un qualcosa di
ieri poi non ho perso il mio ricordato
oggi praticamente stiamo facendo una
sorpresa a mia nonna siamo stati
contattati per un'attività un su
instagram sarò super trasparente da
parte di ceo e che questo sito che
permette la creazione di fotolibri ora
l'attività era solamente per instagram
però credo anche che non sempre si debba
stare troppo lì a dire abbiamo pattuito
questo abbiamo potuto quest'altro cioè
se una cosa ti piace la trovi
tendenzialmente utile stica di quello
che fatto cioè che devi star lì a far
tirchio non lo so questa attività mi è
piaciuto molto perché mi ha permesso di
unire tutti quanti ne cugini nella
creazione di un fotolibro che vorremmo
fare a nostra nonna voglio raccontarvi
questa esperienza io ci ho versato
lacrime della vita questa qui è una foto
dei miei nonni praticamente quando si
sono appena conosciuti guardare questi
siamo tutti nei cugini
ho chiamato 10 perché agosti 10 nipoti e
mi piaceva in realtà ci sono anche foto
di altri cuginetti e quali vogliamo
super bene però non mi piaceva 10 punti
le mani perché te lo faccio vedere
velocemente non voglio ammorbarvi troppo
qui abbiamo
ap i matrimoni vari persone non ci sono
più
oddio sarà quanto pianto a fastoso andrà
veloce andrà veloce prima che mi da
mamma maschi contro femmine abbiamo qui
cugini cugini piccoli ragazzi gianmarco
lo vedete che cos'era poi sempre con i
ragazzi ma gianmarco lo vedete che cos'è
perché non è rimasto così per sempre
proprio vero che quando sono cuccioli
sono più carini miei fratelli
di gabriele bino insieme noi da grandi
giallo ed enrico papi con i no ragazzi e
bellissimo sempre noi tutti quanti
insieme
se questo non le foto che noi facevamo
sempre crescendo ce ne stanno tantissime
poi ci stiamo noi da grandi che fanno un
pochino hi fi che siamo un pochino tutti
quanti a scarsa nascar
yeah yeah yeah pazzeschi pazzeschi
persone persone a me andrò veloce è un
intero dioce bulldog e il duro mourinho
nonna niente sarà vedere un'altra foto
di tutti insieme mio nonno non poter
dare questo photo book a mia nonna e
quindi a darglielo saranno i miei
fratelli ca briatico che stanno passando
al risanamento con lei quindi credo
linea loro non puo essere ne fa piacere
di sicuro una singola di sicuro che si
può avere tante le lacrime stiamo
andando a consegnare un regalo che
consegno ne sono certo che manga la
nonna regalo da parte di chi da parte
degli utenti che tipo una sorta di nome
non vi dico così è molto facile
andiamo a consegnare questo momento
proprio dirlo consegnato le faremo
pulire la cucina o no questo è un regalo
da parte di guglielmi tutti noi per te è
una mano dici che ti piace è mamma mia
ragazzi
continua continua tira fuori mira poi
[Musica]
con questa sei tu e non so che questo
non lo so assieme ad esso di telefono
decide ti piace il caso lo diamo via è
sì se non ti piace pensione lo cambiamo
penso che sia una cosa mia mamma mi ha
tutta una punta da pirlo serve sempre
sulla fine è capitato così divento mamma
mia si sono commossa da ogni volta che
vedo questo mi si stringe il cuore di
gioia ovviamente che è meglio
ac giocarlo e queste sono foto proprio
che sempre selezionata mamma guarda
sembra enrico e mamma questa un certo
vero peso e se mamma ma la mamma lo sa
di questa vale regalo paradiso di queste
zuppiera luciano matrimonio del mezzo so
no no no è che questo qua questa cosa
che francesco si riconosce subito e
questo in sardegna mi sa che sono
cascata sa bene il massimo e per chi lo
doveva dire che quel povero massimo sin
andato così presto
guarda se luciano il suo massimo guarda
questo e giulia peso e carlo alessandra
gianfranco è bello questo gruppo
familiare amico remo e questo a bellino
infatti visto che paolo allora vedi e
questo è
va bene gianluigi questo e come si
chiama bene questo è coso il figlio di
gianfranco questo piglio di chi era ben
noti alcuno le donne esaltiamo andiamo
avanti giriamo della via via besta e
francesca quelle giulia riconosci
francesca non riconoscere due nipoti non
ha veramente questa sete con il nome è
tra i primi tre che qui si è più
francesco che sai che l'altro questo è
una bambina togliere il più non
riconosco un bambino alla vigna ragazzi
alla linea ancora la fine per francia
guarda io tutta romantica con i miei
nipoti grandi e questa che bella la
ringhiosa la spesa per francese i
fratelli hanno monopolizzato un album e
casa abbiamo i bei cicciottelli espositi
ma non tirano belli cicciottelli due
mesi ma mi è questo che è il quale
gianmarco il pio il pivot riguardante
grasso cos'è il bruce e piccolo russo
siamo anche album questo è prezioso che
belliche sono dai andiamo a cambiare che
non ti piace non amano e guglielmo e
jean louis questo bianco e nero non so
chi sia ma adesso io sì mi sembrava è
questo
quella che pensatore li guarda con tutti
e quattro quanto siete belli enrico
tiero io fondavano trovate ste foto
guarda che bello ma perché questo guarda
che fotomodello questo si spacca la
telecamera dove l'avete trovato questa
che ne so non lo so stato fatto apposta
per dire ci ha 40 anni ricopriva fare
più grande di tutti qui sono gianluigi
con enrico un paese foto non l'ho mai
visto ma con le mie mani 10 perde tutti
quanti qua sono dal più grande al più
vicino proprio minuscolo sguardo guarda
sì quello è il vero saperi si farebbe se
girano mano tutto fu micale gabriele ma
ste foto sono state fatte
è questa chi è levino casolari nei box
ribelli queste foto
gianluigi per francesca che giulia
guarda non aggiungere il tavolo da
piccoli e vittoria e alessandro piena
ecco sì enrico con vittoria e gianluigi
non francesca quali sono tutti noi come
se sta bene andiamo avanti guardaci zio
gianfranco via silvani teoria toria che
qui c'è guglielmo la linea del rigore
dimesso col vestitino ma da mangiarsi
porta ci sono ecco lì tre fratelli o
mingo e pino donna ma da mangiarselo
guarda il vestitino e questi tre venduti
solo zio massimo in carriera
mamma mia che bene tutti e due poi c'è
un'altra foto nostra qui c'erano 96
quella che cio sia di generici e poi
anche i capelli corti e poi ci siete due
nella fine crediamo consentite
calo che questo ci è piaciuto piacere è
poco e bellissimo poi tutte le
fotografie belle e tutti i fatti poi
guarda lei sta uscendo da casa in casa
per favore non le ricordiamo che mi fa
male al braccio
no no niente niente ora me le ricordo
tutte come vorrei parlare come un
oggetto ma se va bene ti puoi dire qua
posso parlare e dove non ti preoccupare
io lo faccio vedere se vuol dire puoi
dire qualcosa non certo pure ma no non
sai è un video e coperte un video
guglielmo sei tu il regalo più bello
abbia mai avuto nella mia vita mi viene
da piangere ma io non lo sento però non
lo vedo non ti vedo gioia preferisco
parlare
no sto facendo il video che poi lo
faccio vedere questa che non è pronto
ciao nonna ti è piaciuto guarda lo sai
che in realtà mi sono commosso anche o
farlo tantissimo e tutte le foto
allora infatti dove un attimo spiegare è
da parte mia ma di tutti quanti noi i
nipoti che i nipoti siciliani ognuno ha
buttato dentro tutte le foto che è
riuscito a trovare il sì sì sì quindi
abbiamo fatto una super mega raccolta
che ha fatto piacere quella che in prima
pagina come dice roma come ricorda il
perché avevamo appena fidanzati anni
bella che ci siamo tanti a tutti
sì speriamo speriamo ok invaso dalle
grazie ciao
carina piangerò nel prossimo episodio
io non lo so come si percepisce lio che
rado estremo di felicità ho appena
ricevuto il regalo non un regalo di
compleanno il regalo l'unico regalo per
il mio compleanno una cosa meravigliosa